on s'en remet sur le mercredi 3 novembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque soir nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale accompagnés de nos
invités ainsi que des journalistes de la
rédaction on commence tout de suite avec
les titres de cette édition
la campagne de vaccination contre la
grippe se déroule actuellement en france
une campagne qui cible les personnes de
plus de 65 ans les femmes enceintes ou
encore nommé personne souffrant
d'obésité
seulement l'an dernier la moitié d'entre
eux se sont fait vacciner sont maîtrisés
vous les consignes de tri en france il
reste encore plus de 15 % d'erreurs
d'inattention ou mauvais geste nous
ferons le point au cours d'autres
chroniques environnement du mercredi
siens et puis ces collégiens prépare une
web série autour de la vie de
l'établissement sainte thérèse à
rambouillet osef c'est le nom du projet
il est parrainé par kev adams qui a même
adressé un message de soutien en sans
rebondissement dans la sphère du
chantage présumé à la sextape de mathieu
valbuena karim benzema l'attaquant
français du real de madrid a été placé
en garde à vue ce mercredi matin dans
les locaux de la police judiciaire de
versailles
le footballeur s'y est rendu peu avant 9
heures une information confirmée par le
parquet de versailles qui n'a pas fait
d'autre commentaire
selon sylvain cormier l'avocat de karim
benzema le joueur était prêt à répondre
de lui-même aux questions cela afin de
mettre un terme à la polémique nées de
cette affaire dans laquelle toujours
selon son avocat il n'a pris aucune part
jusqu'à présent trois personnes ont été
mises en examen et placé en détention
provisoire dans cette affaire de
tentative d'extorsion de fonds il y a
quelques semaines le footballeur
français djibril cissé avait lui aussi
été entendu par la police judiciaire de
versailles sans être inquiétés chien et
nous vous en parlions hier lé enquête
sur la mort du jeune moussa victime d'un
tir dans une fusillade à trappes le 1er
mai dernier progresse selon nos
confrères du parisien
un second suspect âgé de 30 ans a été
arrêté cet homme serait l'oncle du
premier homme interpellé hier
il s'est spontanément présenté à la
brigade criminelle de versailles avant
de rejoindre son neveu en garde à vue
les deux hommes sont soupçonnés d'être
les commanditaires d'une exécution qui
visait en fait deux frères du square
albert camus à trappes pour une affaire
de règlement de comptes lié au trafic de
stupéfiants et dont le jeune moussa de
14 ans avait été la victime la sphère
risque d'évoluer rapidement
le juge le juge d'instruction devrait
prendre une décision concernant les deux
hommes toujours en garde à vue hier soir
et cela dans les heures à venir en
rapport avec la faire le ministre de
l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve pourrait
d'ailleurs se rendre à trappes le 13
novembre prochain est toujours attraper
les gardiens d'immeubles et locataires
du square jules védrines sont en colère
depuis plusieurs mois selon leurs dires
un trafic de stupéfiants s'est installé
dans le quartier portes serrures cave et
loches sont dégradées des squats sont
également installées dans les parties
communes
le bailleur est finie ça a été contacté
à plusieurs reprises mais rien n'avait
pas été réparée patrice coulle délégués
du personnel et fidesz a donc signalé un
droit d' alerte pour lui la sécurité de
ses collègues est en danger on les
écoute on a un couple de gardiens qui
sont comme moi agressé verbalement et
physiquement depuis plusieurs mois ça
dure depuis deux mois de février j'ai
ouvert des droitsde alerte vis-à-vis de
mon employeur et rien n'a abouti à la
date d'aujourd'hui ou qu'il ya un manque
de sécurité
ils ne se sentent pas en sécurité ils
ont peur et c'est tout à fait normal ce
que nous a répondu hier la direction
définissent c'est que ça avait un coup
ça coûtait cher donc ils préfèrent
mettre la sécurité la santé de deux de
mes collègues en danger plutôt que de
faire des travaux
nous avons contacté le bailleur est
finie finale et finissent qui n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer sur ce sujet écoutez
le témoignage de stéphane baratiner
gardien d'immeuble il est excédé par ses
conditions de travail ça surtout
commencé vers 2013
on a eu pas mal de caillassages nos
enfants se sont fait menacer à chaque
fois qu'il rentrait de l'école
suite à ça nous on a demandé à déménager
à partir on ne voulait pas nous laisser
partir on nous a dit que les gardiens
doit rester sur place et suite à ça j'ai
fait appel à monsieur coulon le délégué
syndical qui lui a mis tout en oeuvre
pour qu'on puisse nous déménager pour
être plus en sécurité continue sur le
site
pourquoi parce qu'on aime notre travail
on estime que c'est pas à nous de partir
mais ajustements à la société finissent
de faire en sorte qu'on soit en sécurité
sur notre lieu de travail et demain
jeudi se tiendra la première journée
nationale non au harcèlement l'éducation
nationale a décidé de faire de la
prévention contre le harcèlement
l'une de ses priorités cette journée a
été créé pour mobiliser et sensibiliser
les acteurs adultes mais aussi élèves de
sur ce problème de société qui prend de
l'ampleur et touche près de sept cent
mille enfants en france à chaque année
dans les yvelines à versailles c'est au
lycée général technologique et marie
curie que la manifestation aura lieu
nous sommes en ligne avec karina jégou
conseillère au centre académique dead
aux écoles et aux établissements de
l'académie de versailles
mon soir karine anna karina jégo est ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer le but de
cette journée vont pouvoir
établissements et je suis vraiment de
pouvoir le changer le jeu d'abord
ressenti d'abord également tout change
idée qu'il faut faire ou alors parfois
pour de mener tout âge mais aussi
parfois et en comble non ferreux ensuite
sensibiliser leurs camarades au problème
du harcèlement et l'enchère
véritablement dès 17h dans ce que
philippe val qui ont effectué contre
alors comment va se dérouler un petit
peu la journée il ya des ateliers de
prévu des échanges des tables rondes
alors une table ou plus près 5 avec les
leclerc évidemment qui viennent proposer
chacun un angle sur le harcèlement que
je fera par exemple et juridique mais
aussi l'amérique
et puis événement sociétal 1
depuis la nuit des temps ça nous a
invités à chercher à faire et les
surtout de ne pas avoir quelque chose
descendants ne pas avoir des conférences
mais vraiment de faire en sorte que les
jeunes fixer ce prix n'est donc on a
deux et des animations qui font vraiment
d collaboratifs possible de manière à ce
que vraiment les jeunes fois au que vous
êtes manifestation et une fois pas
simplement là pour entendre une bonne
parole
donc vraiment beaucoup trop pour
diminuer les échanges est vraiment
enrichi les professionnels de
l'éducation nationale et les 45 que tous
en forme depuis ce lieu à financer
vraiment la sphère du touch eh bien
merci à karina jégou nous reviendrons
sur cette journée dans le journal de
demain
enfin maintenant direction rambouillet
et le collège sainte-thérèse
sainte-thérèse pardon benjamin pallier
ces élèves de l'atelier cinéma sont en
tournage il tourner une séquence de leur
web si elle comics aux erp l'acronyme de
on s'en fout très utilisée sur internet
le but est de s'initier aux différents
métiers du cinéma tout en s'amusant
retour en images avec reini bourdillon
dans cette séquence 22 plus qu'à deux
doigts sur un micro lumière et caméra
cet après midi les élèves du collège
sainte thérèse de rambouillet sont
concentrés ils tourner une séquence de
leur web série osef devant ou derrière
la caméra tout le monde participe
je joue martin un rigolo rigolo de
service
je joue beaucoup mais on apprend aussi
les rôles de techniciens comme perchiste
enfin là par exemple je faisais
l'assistant réalisateur s'était bas
celui qui dit par exemple silence au
début après moteur pour mettre le moteur
le que ça tourne j'aime bien le fait
qu'on rencontre des comédiens et qu'on
puisse voir ce qui se passe derrière
toutes les scènes et tous les films en
fait ça change tout temps on s'occupe de
plein de choses de la perche on est
ingénieur du son du script et tout mais
aujourd'hui je suis ingénieur du son
donc je dois prendre leçon que jade elle
cherche la websérie osef ce sont des
petites scènes humoristiques mettant en
scène des ados mais aussi des comédiens
professionnels
le scénario a été écrit par l'animateur
de l'atelier cinéma avec l'aide de ses
élèves
ça tourne autour de cet adolescent donc
aux personnalités différentes
donc on retrouve le rigolo de service la
gothique le lascar pour le caïd plus tôt
l'intello enfin toutes les grosses
personnalités qui se démarque chez les
adolescents qu'on peut voir aujourd'hui
qu'on peut rencontrer aujourd'hui et ce
sont des situations humoristiques entre
ces différents personnages qui se
croisent dans des petites scènes
inspirées des séries comiques actuels le
palmashow soda ou encore scènes de
ménages la web série a déjà reçu un
soutien de poids en la personne de kev
adams salut à tous ces cas là que je
soutiens la série osef de benjamin
pallier ainsi que son atelier cinéma
théâtre pour ados et série évidemment et
je vous embrasse tous bijoux tournée
jusqu'en février au collège
sainte-thérèse de rambouillet il faudra
attendre avril pour voir osef sur
internet et ce soir nous recevons le
docteur à frédéric urbain bonsoir à vous
soit remercié devenu notre plateau vous
êtes médecin généraliste à montigny le
bretonneux et vous êtes ici pour nous
parler de la campagne de vaccination
contre la grippe a lors l'épidémie de
grippe en france durant l'hiver 2014
2015 a entraîné une surmortalité record
avec 18300 carrosse ans et c'est l'excès
de mortalité le plus élevé depuis
l'hiver 2006 2007 période à laquelle ce
comptage a débuté pourtant les français
d affectionne ce vaccin anti grippe
alors que davantage envie de vous
est ce que vous êtes favorable ou
défavorable à cette campagne baptisée
vaccination pardon globalement je suis
chauvin vaccination est justement est-ce
que vous avez un petit peu les
explications des raison justement de
cette désaffection des français pour la
vaccination contre la grippe
non je pense que c'est une question qui
fut ministre il faudrait poser un
sociologue de la santé alors j'ai une
opinion personnelle c'est que on va en
parler la vaccination est intéressante
pour certaines personnes pour les
personnes de 2 à risque pour les autres
personnes pour les personnes qui sont
jeunes en bonne santé il le bénéfice
personnel est assez minime en cirque en
fin de compte le risque de la
vaccination est à peu près nulles s'il
existe en tout cas il n'est pas
mesurable tellement est faible et le
bénéfice est assez modérée pour une
personne c'est d'éviter éventuellement
une semaine d'arrêt de travail
en revanche davantage contre les
personnes saines se vaccine séquelles
psychiques personnes qui se vaccinent ne
va pas pouvoir transporter le virus et
donc plus il ya de gens vaccinés plus ça
va protéger les personnes les plus
fragiles alors justement vous parliez
des personnes à risque en france les
derniers chiffres montrent que 50 % des
personnes à risque ne sont pas vaccinés
vous êtes un phénomène que vous
ressentez mais qu'elle soit en ce que
ces personnes au hasard et ce sont
surtout des personnes âgées
alors oui les personnes âgées en premier
lieu toutes les personnes qui sont
porteuses d'une maladie chronique même
si elles ne sont pas j'ai donc bon site
principalement le diabète l'asthme mais
y en a beaucoup d'autres des maladies
qui entraîne une fragilité accrue avec
en plus depuis quelques années deux
populations particulières c'est les
personnes obèses et les femmes enceintes
alors justement pourquoi parmi les
personnes obèses doivent se faire
vacciner passe plus on a observé une sur
mortalité de la grippe chez les
personnes obèses et pour les femmes
enceintes
comment ça se passe en verre pour les
femmes enceintes vrai dire les données
scientifiques sont un tout petit peu
complexe pour une femme enceinte qui n'a
aucune autre maladie on n'est pas
certain encore on est savez c'est un peu
compliqué d'avoir des vérités
scientifiques pour l'instant n'est pas
certain que la vaccination soit
favorable par contre on est certain
qu'elle et son engin alors il ya
beaucoup à l'idée reçue par rapport
justement la vaccination est ce que plus
l'hiver est rude
il est important de se faire vacciner
non il n'y a pas de lien entre la
les températures et l'importance de
l'épidémie alors l'hiver dernier
également le virus a muté le vaccin n'a
pas été aussi efficace que prévu parce
que vous savez si vous nouveau vaccin
est plus efficace et pourquoi justement
celui de l'année dernière n'était pas
parce qu'une virus de la grippe est un
virus très intelligent c'est très
intéressante c'est de s'intéresser avec
grippe ce virus a beaucoup de potentiel
évolutif et il a cette capacité de créer
des mutants qui vont être différent d'un
aspect différent de ceux des souches
précédente ce qui s'est passé l'année
dernière c'est que en fait on
les autorités sanitaires internationales
se réunissent en début d'année pour
déterminer quelle va être la composition
du vaccin de l'année suivante de
l'automne suivant
parce qu'il faut plusieurs mois pour les
fabriquer ces vaccins donc vers février
mars ont dit voilà l'année prochaine il
y aura ces trois souches là dans le
vaccin et de l'année dernière ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'il ya une autre
souche qui entre-temps a émergé et qui
s'est mise à se répandre dans la
population et cette souche est
effectivement moins bien couvertes par
le vaccin
cette année pour l'instant on n'a pas de
souche émergentes résistante et s'éteint
c'est une décision voilà qu'après au
niveau européen au niveau mondial au
niveau peut-être dépit fin ça changera
peut-être non non là où la composition
unique pour toute une ligne pour tout
l'hémisphère nord pour les personnes
justement à risque
c'est vraiment une fin un gros risque
vous l'avez dit au début de la grippe on
n'arrive jamais à mesurer très
précisément le nombre de morts mais
c'est au moins plusieurs milliers de
morts par an on parle justement var
principalement de chez les personnes
âgées et les personnes fragiles mais
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
il ya beaucoup d'idées reçues donc sur
le vaccin de la grippe notamment nous
parle d'aluminium est-ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de délires ont-ils antivaccinal
qui cause du temps justement à cette
campagne
il ya des preuves de communication que
sont les gens ne mesurent peut-être pas
trop l'intérêt
et finalement fin les risques qu'ils
prennent aussi le fond ce l'accent s'ils
ne le font pas issu et du coup par
rapport à justement où le risque
d'aluminium c'est quelque chose qui est
prouvée qui est question vous
conseillerais pas gentil ont peur
peut-être et qui n'osent pas trop ce
sens
je conseille évidemment d'en parler à
leur médecin cdc la première c'est quand
même la ressource qui est supposé être
pertinente pour répondre à leurs
inquiétudes
je peux vous dire c'est qu'effectivement
avec le vaccin antigrippal les
complications sont absolument minimes
quoi c est mise à part les jeunes
peut-être nécessaires au service
peut-être d'autres personnes qu'il faut
qu'à mieux éviter le service et éviter
non il y avait actuellement aucune
contre-indication les rares contre
indications qui existent sont des choses
qui sont bien connues par les messins
d'oxydé personne va consulter son
médecin lui dira si faut pas se dessiner
mais c'est exceptionnel les contre
indications du vaccin antigrippal donc
je vous dise quand je vous parlais de la
population générale la population des
gens en bonne santé
en fait la décision de se vacciner
pourrait reposer sur l'altruisme
c'est simplement protéger les autres en
tant que médecin je suis
déontologiquement obligé de me vacciner
parce que je vais voir dans mon cabinet
des personnes jeunes en bonne santé qui
arrive porteuses du virus qui peuvent me
communiquer ce virus et après je vais
aller voir une personne âgée
à son domicile ou dans une maison de
retraite et je peux lui transmettre ce
virus donc pour moi c'est une obligation
de vacciner ça devrait l'être pour
toutes les personnes qui sont en contact
avec des personnes fragiles et puis pour
les autres encore une fois c'est une
décision altruiste mais je sais pas si
l'altruisme est à la mode actuellement
dans d'autres séries comme ça le début
novembre
il est forcément encore le temps de
faire pour l'instant il est largement
temps depuis dix mille ne pas encore de
mieux démarrer on observe quasiment pas
de virus grippaux pour l'instant donc il
est tout à fait temps je peux pas vous
dire quand est ce qu'il sera trop tard
il est dans certaines années je crois
que c'était il ya deux ans l'épidémie a
été extrêmement tardive est arrivé en
février mars donc ça veut dire qu'il
était encore temps de se vacciner en
janvier on ne peut pas vous pourrez vous
dire à l'avancé quand est-ce que ça va
arriver
s'il n'a pas encore pu y être très peu
de cas de grippe qui sont repérés ce que
ça veut ça ces missions indicateur qui
va être plus fort point forte on peut
pas du tout savoir pour l'instant non
pour justement pour les professionnels
de la santé donc les médecins
généralistes voient font de la
prévention mais les formations par
exemple les infirmières qu'ils sont
suffisamment impliquée justement dans
cette cette démarche de parler de
vaccination je ne sais pas je sais pas
du tout s'ils sont suffisamment
impliqués et vous pensez que peut être
ce serait une bonne chose qu'eux aussi
ont fait plus confiance peut-être à son
pharmacien avait affirmé qu'un médecin
oui et puis s'il ya une je pense quand
même malgré tout quel que soit le poids
des pensées irrationnelles dont vous
avez parlé et qui dont on sait qu'elles
ont une importance psychologique énorme
pour nous malgré tout quand ya une
convergence des discours des
professionnels de santé ça en force
quand même le message alors très
concrètement comment on fait pour se
procurer son son vaccin pour se faire
vacciner voilà si concrètement les gens
qui ne savent pas du tout que leur
diriez vous alors pour ceux qui sont à
risque
ils ont reçu normalement ce qui reçoit
chaque année à papier de la sécurité
sociale qui leur avec lequel il suffit
d'aller à la pharmacie et le pharmacien
va remettre le vaccin il suffit après
soit demander un infirmier soit demandé
aux médecins directement de
d'administrer le vaccin pour ceux qui
sont pas à risque il faut il payer août
une dizaine d'euros effectivement qu'il
a payé de sa poche et enfin une dernière
question avant de conclure cet entretien
quels conseils donneriez-vous afin de se
protéger contre la grippe
si justement on s'est déjà fait vacciner
mais si on ne fait pas fait vacciner
ceux qui ne souhaitent pas se faire
vacciner
voilà ce qu'il ya des petites astuces
des conseils oui oui il faut pas sortir
de chez soi faut pas aller dans les
transports en commun il faut pas
fréquenter des gens voilà complique et
voilà le vaccin plus simple et coutumes
merci frédéric europe 1 est venu nous
parler sur ce plateau est justement du
continent a parlé de la grippe malgré l'
approche de la saison hivernale et la
vaccination contre la grippe il
accompagne les rappels reste aussi très
important c'est pourquoi une fois par
mois
l'institut de promotion de la santé à
trappes organise une séance de
vaccination gratuite
une séance en présence d'un médecin
destinée aux populations peu ou pas
suivi médicalement
regardez ce reportage de williams elle
peut faire et méningite
grâce à cette séance de rappel gratuit
ces personnes originaires du bangladesh
vont pouvoir pour la première fois de
leur vie bénéficier de vaccins organisé
une fois par mois par l'institut de
promotion de la santé à trappes
cette opération permet de venir sans
rendez vous mettre à jour son carnet de
vaccination ont fait en priorité les
vaccinations obligatoires
donc sur tout le disque hérite d'un
polio et après on peut en fait aussi des
vaccinations qui sont très recommandé
l'hépatite b le ror rougeole oreillons
et rubéole peut informer les populations
les moins suivis médicalement n'ont
souvent jamais eu accès à ces vaccins un
an auparavant
les patients ont d'abord un entretien
avec l'infirmière souvent difficile à
cause de la barrière de la langue
c'est souvent des étrangers
c'est souvent des zi c'est les gens qui
sont démunis ou qui sont réfugiés les
heureuses quelques fois le questionnaire
très difficile puisqu'il parle très peu
ou très mal le français
à la fin de la consultation un carnet de
vaccination et remis aux patients s'ils
n'en avaient pas auparavant
pour l'instant à l'essai ces séances
permettent également de se faire
vacciner contre la grippe à condition
d'apporter son propre vaccin
avez vous fait une bonne action cette
année si ce n'est pas le cas et que vous
y pensez cette information peut vous
intéresser
la fédération des yvelines du secours
populaire français recherchent des
bénévoles pour son opération paquets
cadeaux du 21 novembre au 27 décembre
ces bénévoles vous proposeront de faire
vos paquets cadeaux à la sortie des
magasins en échange d'une participation
volontaire c'est également un moyen de
mieux faire connaître au grand public
leurs actions de solidarité alors si l
approche de l vous souhaitez donner de
votre temps pour faire une bonne action
n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner plus
d'informations sur le site internet
www.solucom.fr tirer 78 et enfin vous en
avez l'habitude le mercredi on parle
environnement et développement durable
avec mélanie poker et cette semaine nous
allons nous intéresser au tri sélectif
et notamment au logo que l'on trouve sur
les emballages
bonsoir mais la nissim s'enflamme alors
avant de commencer j'aimerais vous poser
une question savez vous ce que
représente ce logo alors ce beaucoup à
l'écran alors ça veut dire que c'est
recyclables emballages recyclables
malheureusement non plus on aime ce logo
on l'appelle le point vert il signifie
que l'entreprise contribue
financièrement recyclage des emballages
on le trouve sur 95% des emballages
commercialisé en france et il ne veut
pas dire que l'emballage est recyclable
alors les logos sont nombreux et
différents il n'est pas toujours facile
de s'y retrouver
nous sommes allés à votre rencontre pour
vous soumettre trois logos oui non oui
il vous dira quoi aux papiers emballages
ouais le troisième ça s'est pas jeté à
la poubelle
ça s'est produit à recycler les papiers
dans une poubelle
oui alors là aucune idée quelques le 2e
2e marchait pas la poubelle peut-être
et l'autre non non pas du tout le
deuxième aussi les poubelles de quartier
je suppose et le troisième bien je sais
pas non plus on l'a vu mais l'année je
ne suis pas la seule à me tromper
après vous savez il ya des erreurs
surtout les logos les deux autres que
vous avez vu ce sont le trim ain et le
teil du man alors le trim annales et il
a été initié par l'état
il signifie que le produit doit être
triés ou rapportés dans un point de
collecte il est obligatoire sur tous les
produits recyclables ou emballages sauf
le vert depuis le début de l'année le
dernier c'est le tide human c'est une
simplicité incitation à la propreté
il invite chacun d'entre nous à jeter
nos déchets dans une poubelle alors on
avait trois mais comment être sûr
vraiment de ne pas se tromper mais des
erreurs il y en aura toujours il faut
savoir que 15 % des déchets collectés ne
sont pas recyclables tout de même pour
éviter ces erreurs eco emballages qui
est une entreprise agréée par l'état a
mis en place depuis deux ans de
nouvelles signalétiques et notamment des
consignes de tri les logos sont ainsi
accompagnés de petite notice explicative
aurélie marcela les chargés de
communication éco emballages eve les
explique
vous avez un petit poubelles grill qui
vous dit sachets plastiques et
barquettes plastiques à jeter et un clip
à john qui vous dit cartonnage
cartonnait cartons emballages carton a
reculé par près de 40 milliards de
pâques sont aujourd'hui concernés ces 40
milliards sur 90 milliards qui sont en
france donc les consignes sont de plus
en plus présentes ce qui permet de
faciliter le tri nous sommes allés vous
demandez quand même si vous pensez le
faire correctement bien je sais pas mais
oui je trie oui c'est normal après on
essaie de faire au maximum et
quelquefois on a des déchirements ses
patrouilles les maîtres et c'est un peu
difficile
j'ai trois poubelles pour les verts pour
le
comment s'appellent les déchets ménagers
et les cartons et bouteilles de
plastique montrer le papier les aliments
puis les déchets qui peuvent varier
j'ai un bac à moi et à chaque fois quand
je vois je lis sur le produit et puis
après voilà cissé a ajouté je jette et 6
à recycler je le mets dans back après je
mets dans le canton comme c'est marqué
dans le journal montigny ya longtemps à
si vous avez un doute vu j'étais alors
mélanie on l'a vu les réponses sont
diverses escales loterie est devenu
vraiment un geste quotidien pour les
français ça dépend de la région et du
lieu où on vit faut savoir contrer quand
même bien moins en ville qu'à la
campagne et l'île de france on ne fait
malheureusement pas partie des meilleurs
élèves puisque nous trions parents 31 kg
d'emballages ménagers la moyenne
française
elle est de 46 kg avec totalement entré
dans les moeurs 20 ans 20 ans n'est pas
faits l'un pour le recyclage 2008 pour
finir à 3 fond de fête pour fins vous
voyez la marge de progrès la extrêmement
rapide et quand vous interrogez
aujourd'hui les français sur leurs
réflexes environnementaux il vous disant
un jet de prix c'est même devenu un acte
éco citoyen alors on l'a entendu à
mélanie le taux de tri donc de 67 %
aujourd'hui
est ce que dans un futur proche on peut
imaginer qu'il y aura plus de déchets
qui seront recyclés dans ça stagne pas
ce que l'on a entendu ses limites et
très très vite malgré tout certains
essaient de trouver des solutions éco
emballages cherche notamment à trier
tous les plastiques
aujourd'hui on ne recycle que les
bouteilles et les flacons d'ici 2022
l'entreprise espère pouvoir trier aussi
des pots de yaourt ou de la crème
fraîche pour cela il faut quand même
moderniser les centres de tri pour
séparer les différentes raisons qui
composent les emballages alors on parle
beaucoup de l'importance du tri c'est
normal mais ce que les conséquences de
ce geste sont quantifiables mais déjà
trié ses emballages s'est pas seulement
une lubie chaque année trier permet
d'éviter deux millions de tonnes de gaz
à effet de serre en france ça et que ça
équivaut à un million de voitures en
moins sur les routes
il faut savoir que montigny le
bretonneux et l'encours et rap ont été
sélectionnés par eco emballages pour
densifier les points d'apport volontaire
et renforcer la mobilisation locale en
2016 floral
il ne nous reste
plus qu adopter le bon geste merci
beaucoup à mélanie c'est maintenant la
fin de cette édition je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivis tout de suite restez
avec nous vous avez rendez vous avec
sephora de la vanille pour une nouvelle
édition de kiosques que votre magazine
culturel quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain à 18 heures à 18 heures pardon
pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8 est le
journal en direct avec la chronique
sportive de nickel à lui d'euros je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée